[Música]
continúa la búsqueda masiva de cientos
de migrantes desaparecidos en el mar
griego tras el mayor naufragio de este
año ayer en el Mediterráneo murieron al
menos 78 personas y hay 106
supervivientes recibiendo atención
mientras el país está de luto nacional
el ex Primer Ministro de Reino Unido
Johnson mintió deliberadamente al
parlamento es la conclusión de la
comisión que Investiga el escándalo del
partygate las fiestas en Downey Street
durante la pandemia de covid-19 tenemos
reportes de Londres
Rusia atacó el puerto de Odessa y
volvieron a caer misiles contra crit la
ciudad natal del presidente voló
a su turno denunció que ataques de kiev
mataron a un menor en la ocupada jerson
en tanto el jefe nuclear de la ONU
visita la planta de saporilla tenemos el
reporte de nuestra enviada especial al
terreno
Buenos días Bienvenidos a las noticias
de France 24 en español Soy Rosa Pérez
más deu y es para mí un gusto
acompañarles abrimos esta edición
informativa en Grecia Por qué
rescatistas Siguen trabajando para
encontrar asientos de víctimas de un
naufragio cerca de las costas del sur
griego Se confirma el fallecimiento de
al menos 78 personas y los 106
supervivientes se recuperan bajo el ala
del gobierno que declaró tres días de
luto nacional en los últimos 10 años
27.000 personas han muerto intentando
llegar a Europa a través del
Mediterráneo la frontera más mortífera
del mundo
esto es refugiados son sobrevivientes de
naufragios rescatados por la armada
griega se organizan rápidamente y luego
se suben a bordo de un helicóptero de la
fuerza aérea su destino kalamata sur de
Grecia aquí lo sobrevivientes son
traídos con el apoyo de la Cruz Roja o
el alto comisionado de las Naciones
Unidas para los refugiados
están muy conmocionados quien no estaría
conmocionado después de experimentar un
naufragio esperamos encontrar más
sobrevivientes
el número de pasajeros que iban a bordo
del barco Aún es incierto según testigos
podrían ser hasta 750
ahora las autoridades griegas
sobrevuelan la zona en búsqueda de otros
sobrevivientes
según la guardia costera el motor del
barco se descompuso durante la madrugada
del 13 al 14 de junio y se hundió en
aguas muy profundas
la mayoría de las víctimas son de Egipto
Pakistán y Siria se cree que el barco
salió de Libia rumbo a Italia tomando
una de las rutas migratorias más
mortíferas del mundo
el gobierno griego Se declaró el luto
nacional
hoy todos están conmocionados
incluido el gobierno el Primer Ministro
ha declarado un luto de tres días en
memoria de las víctimas del trágico
accidente pero también todas las
víctimas de Los contrabandistas sin
escrúpulos que explota la miseria humana
una tragedia que recuerda a otra
ocurrida el pasado mes de febrero un
barco de madera se estrelló contra las
rocas a pocos metros de la costa
italiana alrededor de 100 personas
perdieron la vida incluidos al menos
ocho niños un accidente que aún es
motivo de investigación
vamos ahora Reino Unido porque el ex
Primer Ministro Boris Johnson mintió
deliberadamente al parlamento británico
Esta es la conclusión a la que ha
llegado la comisión que Investiga el
caso del Party los detalles anunos los
entregó desde Londres nuestra
corresponsal Luisa Pulido
recomendó que si Johnson no hubiera
renunciado como lo hizo el viernes
pasado hubiera suspendido su hubiera
sido suspendido Por 90 días que es un
castigo mucho mayor de lo que se
esperaba porque automáticamente casi
perdería su silla en el parlamento
británico como lo mencionaba se concluyó
en este informe que Johnson mintió no
solamente una sino varias veces en lo
que él llamó reuniones de trabajo porque
se rompieron todas las leyes del
distanciamiento Social esta
recomendación es bien bien interesante y
extraordinaria porque la recomienda que
Boris Johnson no obtenga el pase de
exdiputado lo que evitaría que ingresara
fácilmente al edificio de Westminster
Esta es en esencia una investigación
política que tendrá que ser votada el
próximo lunes y así se sabrá si Los
partidarios conservadores de Johnson aún
mantienen su papel mantienen el apoyo o
si ya están con el actual Primer
Ministro
cambiamos ahora de información vamos con
noticias de la guerra en Ucrania porque
el puerto de Odessa en el sur del país
volvió a ser objetivo de la ofensiva
rusa por segundo día consecutivo por
otro lado la ciudad natal del presidente
voló dimir selenski también recibió
varios ataques mientras
Moscú denuncia que los ataques de kiev
mataron a un menor en la zona de la
región de gersón ocupada por las fuerzas
del kremlin además las fuerzas rusas
aseguran que han neutralizado nueve
drones sobre la Península de crimea
en otras noticias de la Guerra de
Ucrania el kremlin dijo que no veía
perspectivas positivas respecto a la
renovación del acuerdo de granos del mar
Negro dado que partes del acuerdo que
afectan directamente a Rusia Siguen sin
cumplirse el portavoz del kremlin
Dimitri pescoff se pronunció sobre el
tema
si está trabajando pero la verdad es que
no vemos perspectivas especialmente
positivas no las vemos porque no se ha
cumplido todo lo que se acordó con
respecto a nosotros de eso partimos no
nos apresuremos
el partido liberal de oposición de
Australia expulsó al senador David Band
señalado por su colega independiente
Lidia zorp quien lo acusó de agredirla
sexualmente en el mismo parlamento van
mantiene su escaño pero pierde la
afiliación a su grupo político y será
investigado además negó las acusaciones
que se hicieron bajo privilegio
parlamentario thorp le dijo al pleno que
el político la tocó y amenazó en una
escalera donde no había cámaras por la
época en la que se conoció la
investigación independiente que probó la
violencia sexual en el hemiciclo hace
cerca de un año
el ejército de Israel mató un joven
palestino y dio a otros dos durante una
redada en nablus en sir Jordania ocupada
los detalles los tiene nuestro
corresponsal en Jerusalén para Israel y
los territorios palestinos Federico cué
Barberena
un palestino de 20 años murió y otros
dos resultaron heridos en una nueva
redada del ejército israelí en la blues
una de las ciudades de si Jordania
ocupada donde se han producido más
incursiones militares en el último año y
medio con vehículos blindados o las
fuerzas israelíes entraron en la ciudad
para demorar la vivienda de Osama tahuil
un miembro de La milicia Guarida de los
leones que está preso acusado de
participar en el asesinato del Soldado
israelí ido Baruc en octubre pasado en
los enfrentamientos el ejército israelí
mató al joven de un disparo en la cabeza
según el Ministerio de salud palestino
mientras que entre los heridos uno se
encuentra en estado crítico además en la
media luna roja Palestina reportó que
170 personas debieron ser tratadas por
síntomas de asfixia a causa de los gases
lacrimógenos arrojados por las tropas
israelíes horas después las fuerzas
israeleces derribaron la casa familiar
de tahuil en la que también vivían los
padres y la hermana del atacante
mientras que también está programada la
destrucción de las viviendas de los
otros los dos acusados de participar en
el ataque contra el soldado Baruc estas
demoliciones son una práctica habitual
de Israel que la se justifica como un
elemento de disuasión pero es denunciada
por los grupos de Derechos Humanos como
un castigo colectivo Injusto e incluso
dentro del establecimiento de seguridad
de Israel es cuestionada su efectividad
en desalentar posibles futuros ataques
así en este año el más mortífero desde
la segunda intifada ya son al menos 125
los palestinos muertos por fuego Israel
en Jordania ocupada entre ellos en
varios civiles y 21 menores
cambiamos de tema porque Corea del Norte
pone de nuevo en alerta a la región con
el lanzamiento de dos misiles de corto
alcance el Primer Ministro japonés se
condenó los disparos que cayeron en
aguas japonesas coincidiendo con la
visita del asesor de seguridad Nacional
de Estados Unidos Jake Sullivan a Tokio
el lanzamiento se produjo después de que
pyongyang protestara contra los
simulacros militares conjuntos entre las
fuerzas de Washington y de seúl
considerados los más grandes de la
historia
vamos ahora con noticias de América
Latina porque en la provincia de Buenos
Aires la iniciativa de una mujer permite
alimentar diariamente a varias familias
que de otra forma No podrían hacer
frente a una inflación desbocada que en
mayo alcanzó el
114,2% interanual sobre la crisis
económica nos habla humana
multiplicar la solidaridad Anahí Robledo
un antiguo trabajadora doméstica que
lleva ahora un comedor solidario
alimentaba hace poco a unas 15 familias
diarias con su sopa comunitaria hoy son
hasta 50 las familias en José Clemente
Paz A las afueras de Buenos Aires que
dependen de ella para aliviar el hambre
me pone triste porque esto nada cambió
nada cambio y todo sigue peor
a mí me gustaría que cada familia tenga
un plato de comida en su mesa que pueda
comer con sus hijos y no venir a un
comedor a buscar un plato de comida
cuatro de cada diez personas en
Argentina han caído en la pobreza en
medio de una inflación que ha alcanzado
el
114,2% en los últimos 12 meses solo el
precio de los alimentos fue en mayo 5,8%
Más alto que en el mes anterior a pesar
de una leve desaceleración y Eso incluye
los ingredientes que analice las ingenia
para conseguir entre productos
descartados nosotros vamos al mercado
concentrador y de ahí sacamos la verdura
cuando salen los chicos para tirarla
nosotros las agarramos las limpiamos las
picamos las frisamos y ahí tenemos para
cocinar la inflación la debilidad de la
moneda local frente al Dólar y el
endeudamiento contribuyen a alargar la
fila de los que cada día dependen de
comedores solidarios como este en todo
el país para alimentar se
pasamos ahora a Canadá donde el Primer
Ministro rastín artudó advirtió que los
fenómenos meteorológicos extremos serán
cada vez más comunes y en medio de la
oleada de incendios que azota el país
varios países han enviado bomberos de
apoyo
con el peor inicio de temporada de
incendios forestales de su historia
Canadá pide ayuda a sus aliados el
miércoles Portugal se convirtió en el
último país en enviar un contingente de
bomberos en apoyo
Portugal ha expresado una vez más su
solidaridad enviando 140 bomberos
estarán sobre el terreno durante 15 días
Para apoyar a las fuerzas canadienses
Canadá lleva meses luchando contra una
oleada de incendios forestales cada vez
más agresivos y que están Arrasando sus
bosques ya se han quemado más de 13
millones de hectáreas una superficie
mayor que la de Países Bajos el
miércoles en la agencia de incendios
forestales del país informó que cerca de
460 incendios seguían activos
234 de ellos fuera de control el Primer
Ministro Justin trudó que se reunió el
miércoles con miembros de las fuerzas
armadas advirtió que la situación aún
puede empeorar obviamente estamos viendo
un aumento de los fenómenos astrológicos
extremos el aumento de los incendios
forestales en todo el país y lo haremos
en los próximos años debido a los
impactos de la crisis climática Así que
estamos discutiendo mucho sobre cómo
asegurarnos de que estamos preparados
para ello la mayoría de los incendios
fueron causados por fenómenos naturales
como tormentas sin embargo los
científicos han advertido que están
siendo aún más graves por la crisis
climática Y es que aunque los incendios
forestales de verano son habituales en
Canadá el alcance y el inicio del
desastre actual es que comenzó en marzo
han hecho que el país esté ahora en un
territorio desconocido
y cerramos en París donde desde este
miércoles y hasta el sábado se realiza
vivatec se trata de la feria de
tecnología más importante de Europa y
nuestra periodista Natalia Ruiz nos lo
cuenta
la feria tecnológica vivatec es un
gigante Laberinto en donde más de 2400
startups principalmente de Europa vienen
a presentar sus diferentes productos hay
de todos los gustos o para todos los
gustos que sea de Inteligencia
artificial que sea también para
inteligencia militar y otras cosas que
se pueden aplicar más para el día a día
como esta empresa de Estados Unidos
basada en Ohio que ha creado un
neumático que no se pincha Así que
parece que los neumáticos desinflados
pueden ser cosa del pasado
fabricamos llantas sin aire basadas en
una tecnología de la NASA es una
aleación de memoria de forma que se usó
en el programa del Rover que explora
Marte fabricamos llantas sin aire para
varios mercados motos bicicletas y
eventualmente para automóviles como no
tiene aire quiere decir que no se
pinchan y tampoco necesitan
mantenimiento pero con el mismo
desempeño y calidad del transporte de
una llanta normal la movilidad es uno de
los temas
presentados uno de los que más ha
llamado la atención es este que debe ser
comercializado a partir del próximo año
únicamente en Estados Unidos por
cuestiones de reglamentación
que es como una especie de moto aérea
que tiene tres computadores y que no se
va a necesitar siquiera una licencia de
piloto para poder volar
es una máquina que tiene cuatro motores
térmicos y ocho motores eléctricos es
una máquina de propulsión
híbrida distribuida los motores térmicos
sustentan la máquina para permitirle de
colar y los motores eléctricos son los
que la estabilizan los que le permiten
realizar maniobras y aceleraciones y
desestabilizarla a Baja velocidad y nos
despedimos desde y esta será una de las
cápsulas de lo futuro que nos va a
transportar no solamente en la ciudad
desde una tecnología completamente
eléctrica sino que también puede ir a
buscarnos a nuestras casas a la puerta
de nuestra casa o de nuestra oficina
esta empresa italiana como muchas otras
de las presentes aquí esperan Buscar la
financiación para poder continuar con
este proyecto el año pasado se
colectaron en total 13.500 millones de
euros
hasta que las noticias
[Música]